have you been to rolling loud
yet in life i did rolling out of miami
2019
oh that was like the real [ __ ] up year
yeah the [ __ ] with the big a riot and
[ __ ]
oh yeah that was there yeah that was
some real yo it's crazy because
i was that was the year that josh
jackson from the phoenix suns got
arrested for trying to get backstage
that's crazy and i'm a son's fan i was
like yo i heard a [ __ ] rolling loud
that year was a [ __ ] just a free
it was like a rapper free-for-all out
there nah that [ __ ] was fire
i got down i came out my trailer and
tiana trump
walked right what the [ __ ] tiana trump
walked by what you say
i ain't saying [ __ ] that [ __ ] caught me
off guard you're a fan
yeah she's great she is great she's
great yeah
she's amazing yeah i always tell anybody
just go to
good or twitter she got the pinned video
at the top that tells peop tells you
exactly why people love her right there
off the rip
she's she's a legend bro she is like who
else are legends in the porn game to you
i don't know like that no i don't i
ain't white porn
for real like and since probably i was
like
20 something like this [ __ ] guy so yo
tiara trump walk by i was excited now
i mean she like that's like knowing who
got them
i don't know if you that's like knowing
guy fieri if you don't know chefs but
you know you know so you know that [ __ ]
like
so you're saying the only porn star you
know is tiana trump
ah so who else
um
i can't you well if you if you saying
you say your name and i'll be like
okay i know that see now so now you're
putting it on me to be there
because i don't i can't think enough i
can't think of like
we can go down the list i know i could
if they face i can see their face and be
like oh
they that's a porn style yeah pinky
okay yeah okay see i wouldn't even
thought of her but that's something oh
[ __ ]
that's something yeah she was like a
[ __ ] that was like the 2000s she was
like a fat little [ __ ]
chick nah nah no no no i met her in
person at the avians
she's a short little lady man she's
that's why she she was so thick because
she was like stubby
shout out shout out to pinky man she a
legend man